I want to show people the
direct connection between woke ideas in
schools that that James is talking about
and then how these people end up quite
literally in our government often
handling things as important as uh
immigration check this out from the
daily wire the US immigration
enforcement agency hired a former
spokeswoman for the Palestinian Liber
Liberation Organization the PLO and put
her in a position to determine who gets
to come into the country as an immigrant
or asyl Seeker now the Department of
Homeland Security Officer is repeatedly
posting pictures of Hamas terrorist
terrorists parachuting in with guns and
writing F Israel and any Jew who
supports Israel a dailywire
investigation found Nua Ali worked in
2016 and 2017 as a public affairs
officer for the palestini Palestinian
delegation to the US which according to
its own website served as the PLO office
in DC that office office was expelled
from the country uh by the Trump
Administration but Ali landed on her
feet according to a screenshot of her
LinkedIn profile securing a job at DHS
as an asylum officer where she was
tasked with applying immigration laws
and regulations to Asylum applications
this January she moved over to being an
adjudication officer for the US
citizenship and Immigration Services
people with that job according to the
agency analyze new or amended
legislation and policy prepare written
reports and findings and review and make
determinations on cases for immigration
benefits Melissa this is particularly
important because suddenly Jamal Bowman
AOC Rashida Talib they're saying that we
should take in a million Gins and do you
think that maybe we don't have the best
of the best vetting these people or I
guess a more cynical version would be
that we actually have enemies within
that are glad to let some bad people in
yeah absolutely I you know I I think
it's we deserve to find out what
happened there how on Earth did the the
fox you know get in charge of of the
chicken Coupe um want to jump back a
little bit on on the uh connecting all
that dots and and why this particular
story should alarm us all it's that you
know when when I saw these protests uh
in in New York City in Times Square
there were signs and that that said
resistance is not terrorism and that
word was very very prevalent during the
the the four years of the Trump admin
you heard resistance all the time um
it's also what antifa and BLM thought
they were doing um they under the banner
of resistance they Justified burning
they Justified looting um you know
beating up conservative journalists to a
pulp you can justify so much under the
banner resistance and that's how people
are justifying now what Hamas is doing
as well and in the mindset of these
people you know where you have this
bundle of ideas that kind of get like
swallowed wholesale everywhere
everything from you know decolonization
to anti-racism and everything and by the
way decolonization it's very clear that
this radical rhetoric with zero limiting
principles was not merely just a call to
rid curricula of Mozart and Shakespeare
uh it turns out and and I think you know
the left is waking up to that that it's
far far far more sinister
um and and so for someone like nja is
that her name who is working for the
DHS I I don't know the exact
pronunciation but hopefully we don't
know need to know her name after this by
the way I should note that she's on
leave as of yesterday so there is I
guess a bit of a silver lining here good
but you can imagine that somebody with
that kind of mindset of resistance what
they would be willing to do in that
capacity in order to achieve their
political goals and that's what makes
them dangerous